[Music]
My dear grandchildren When I was your
age the sea was already at the center of
my life growing up in Malta the blue
Mediterranean is everywhere the sea is
very much a part of the family
it's our past our present our future
I am the European Commissioner for
Environment maritime affairs and
Fisheries that means that it is my job
to protect nature to protect fish and
other marine animals but also to help
the fishermen the sailors and all people
who live from the sea to ensure that we
benefit from the rich resources of the
sea whilst preserving them for future
generations for you
you see is facing more and more dangers
in some areas we fish too much plastic
fills up our ocean our planet is getting
warmer with damaging effects on life in
the ocean we can solve all these
problems working together and that is
why I am both proud and hopeful when
this year in October hundreds of world
leaders politicians ocean lovers will
gather together in our island of Malta
to find a solution and to take the
concrete commitments to act for cleaner
for safer and for healthier sea
their grandchildren my ocean is your
ocean my ocean is our ocean
[Music]